le saga du conte chromate à savoir un
présumé de ces compromettant russe
contre donald trump semble se clarifier
au fil des jours l'analyste igor
tkatchenko qui récolter des données sur
l'ex président pour ce dossier aurait
menti au fbi quant aux sauces de ces
informations n'ont pas une ou deux fois
mais cinq les autorités ont arrêté un
analyste contribuant au dossier style
igor didenko un analyste russe qui a
travaillé avec christopher style
l'auteur de rapports contenant des
rumeurs et des affirmations sans preuve
sur donald trump a été inculpé dans le
cadre de l' enquête de durham pour ceux
qui auraient oublié c'est une belle
histoire en voici un résumé en existions
britannique du mi6 christophe are still
a monté un dossier sur donald trump sur
commande de ses adversaires politiques
contenant des informations
compromettantes s'il travaillait pour la
société fiuggi pièce qui à son tour
travaillé pour une société juridique
représentant le parti démocrate
américain et la campagne présidentielle
d'hillary clinton un 2016 afin de
préparer son dossier si cette année
c'est un analyste d'origine russe vivant
aux etats unis igor dantchenko
christopher s'il était très fière de son
dossier mais reconnaissait quelques
petits mais vraiment petit souci c'était
un rapport crédible nous savions que
certaines informations étaient fiables
et soupçonnions que certaines d'entre
elles pourraient ne jamais être prouvé
je pense que certaines parties du
dossier ont été confirmés et d'autres ne
l'ont pas été il y à un ou deux éléments
qui se sont révélé être faux je suis
prêt à admettre que certaines
informations contenues dans le dossier
ne sont pas fiables à 100% selon ce
dossier notamment les services secrets
russes auraient été en possession d'un
enregistrement de donald trump en pleine
orgie avec des prostituées dans une
suite présidentielle de ritz carlton de
moscou et ces enregistrements auraient
été utilisés par vladimir poutine en
personne pour faire du président
américain une marionnette à la seule de
la russie ces allégations avaient à
l'époque fait rire le président russe
je peux difficilement imaginer qu'ils se
soient précipités à l'hôtel pour
rencontrer ses filles à la
responsabilité sociale réduite même si
bien sûr ce sont les meilleurs au monde
je doute que tron se soit laissé tenté
par cela
même les médias américains qui ont
publié le dossier de christopher style
n'ont pas pu confirmer ces allégations
pourtant ça a été tout de même suffisant
pour que le fbi ouvre une enquête sur
donald trump et son entourage une
investigation baptisé crossfire
hurricaines ouragans feux croisés en
français s'est alors abattue sur l'ex
président américain cette investigation
s'est ensuite transformé en la fameuse
enquête du procureur spécial robert
müller qui à son tour n'a pas trouvé de
preuve de collusion entre trump est là
aussi taïpei ils ont basé toute cette
surveillance sur des mensonges encore
des mensonges les uns à la suite des
autres tout a été cousu main est classé
dans ce qu'on appelle un dossier pour je
ne sais quelle raison un tissu de
mensonges a été mis au premier plan lui
donnant ce nom ultra pompeï clinquant
avec dossier tous ces hommes de loi qui
ont défilé en affirmant qu'il y avait
collusion entre trump et les rues et
bien tout était basée sur des mensonges
vous allez me dire sérieusement que
personne ne le savait aux personnes en
écoutant ces histoires ne s'exclamer
combien c'était ridicule combien c'était
absurde ou non ils ont gardé le cap car
ils avaient l'impression que personne
n'allait les arrêtés qu'ils avaient une
impunité c'est contre treuil on s'en
fiche parce qu'à cette époque tout ce
qui concerne être ça passait et si vous
ajoutez un soupçon de russie oh mon dieu
c'est l intrigue john durham est un
procureur terre à terre la plupart
d'entre nous n'ont pas oublié et bien
maintenant il est apparemment en train
de repartir de plus belle et laissez-moi
vous dire quelque chose il était temps
le procureur spécial de département
américain de la justice john durham
enquête sur la légalité et la bonne
tenue de l'investigation crossfire
hurricaines depuis mai 2010 neuf et l'a
déjà inculpé deux figurants l'un aurait
vous dit hamel pour obtenir
l'autorisation de placer sur les coûtant
membre de la campagne de trolls et
l'autre aurait fourni des informations
et des en cachant ses liens avec la
campagne d'hillary clinton et garonne
jean cau et le troisième à faire face à
des accusations il ne sera peut-être pas
le dernier